qu'est-ce qui m'est arrivé comment le laisser
m'aveugler comme ça, je ne sais pas combien
de fois ont été rayés de la
liste suffisamment pour la journée, donc ce n'est
pas nouveau
quand nous avons fait les Chroniques de Riddick, nous
envisagions en fait de faire trois films que
nous avions toujours  nous a demandé de continuer que
les nouveaux fans de la franchise ont dit s'il vous plaît faites ce
film, il y a une question de savoir où nous allons
ensuite et pour servir la mythologie, vous deviez le
placer dans un environnement
similaire au noir absolu et oui, cela maintient
la question vivante où est-il  en cours,
nous nous sommes rapidement installés dans une histoire qui a
trouvé Riddick laissé pour mort dans un
monde extraterrestre assez exotique,
c'est censé être des soucis de quelques secondes,
il se rend compte que ce n'est pas de la peur et qu'il a
personne ne veut être sur cette planète dans 24
heures juste eu une chose dans  ma parole
prête depuis 10 ans est l'homme le plus
dangereux qui ait jamais suivi ce film, il
se bat contre un environnement hostile pour
s'en sortir et survivre,
c'est aussi une maison sécurisée
Je viens chercher ta tête dans une boîte
ici encore une fois
nous jouons pour le sang c'est sombre et
viscéral
l'homme qui voit dans le noir attention
aux surprises qu'est-ce qu'il se
passe ouais laissons le lâcher